hello lovely people can you believe it
we are getting an update on skull and
bones ubisoft announced there would be a
skull and bones presentation a few days
ago and if you don't remember this is a
pirate game that was announced years and
years and years ago like pre-pandemic
i'm pretty sure if i remember correctly
and then just kind of disappeared went
dead silent which i'm in favor of it
gives us some more distance from black
flag um which i spent a lot of time
doing boat stuff in i'm okay with them
being a little bit further apart
but had
guessed that the game wasn't going to
exist anymore uh so i guess that's wrong
it's here we have three videos to watch
i have
the skullenbones long live privacy
cinematic trailer
a gameplay overview trailer and some
ship customization so let's start with
the cinematic trailer shall we this is
two and two minutes and 50 seconds
yeah i guess we've got characters to
meet i don't know who this game's about
i don't know
society has rules
it decides where you belong
good looking fruit and what you're worth
but you
you can chart a new course maybe not
then maybe maybe it won't
be that story heavy when it gives me the
you you can start a new
chart a new course that sounds like a
character creator
even when death
seems a certainty
do not give up
wow that looks beautiful i should make
myself smaller sorry on the shores of a
new world
you
awaken
okay
more determined than ever
to carve a life
of your choice
fighting under our own so i guess you'll
slowly recruit more people and get
bigger
ships it's like a thought
together
we will take on the world
this is beautiful
society
but today
you decide where you belong i don't like
that it's saying something to you
[Music]
now choose
will you live as pawns
or die
as pirates
very pretty trailer
um oh still got a little bit left
8th of november there you go look at us
getting release dates
register for live tests okay so
is this an online only game i'm sure
that some of the extra videos we're
about to watch will get there but
i
came up with the expectation which is my
fault that the cinematic trailer would
have some story focus to it
um which is probably just a thing i
expect from a ubisoft game and i'm now
thinking it's probably more like a
realistic sea of thieves than i had
originally expected um
and based on the like showing up at this
island and there being a shark fin in
the water i was like oh they're gonna do
like some far cry stuff there's probably
gonna be you know find hidden treasure
or whatever the [ __ ] on that island
skin animals to get upgrades for your
ship uh but yeah i'm wondering if
gameplay wise
outside of obviously being more
realistic probably a bit more gritty how
it'll differentiate differentiate itself
from sea of thieves if it's an online
only thing
which is just kind of how it sounds um
interesting to ps4
okay let's check out the gameplay
overview probably some of my questions
that will be answered
uh and i could be wrong about everything
gameplay overview trailer let's go
very pretty welcome to skull and bones
our game takes place during the golden
age of piracy in a world inspired by the
beautiful yet dangerous indian ocean
you'll start your journey as an outcast
whose goal is to become the most
infamous pirate to sail these
attractions that makes me sick
is it a survival after surviving a
shipwreck you begin your adventure in
saint ann one of the pirate dens in our
world dens are centers of pirate
activity where you can craft new ships
and equipment provision for your
expeditions at sea pick up contracts
with other players
so it is online any pirate worth their
salt will tell you that preparation is
key to success
get ready for any challenges that come
your way by checking that your cargo is
stocked with items like food and
ammunition
once you're set it's time to head out
and explore
yeah i wonder if there's a character if
this guy is a character you'll only have
access to a small dow
but as you progress you'll be able to
craft different ships each with their
own unique playstyle it's definitely fun
at sea you'll need to pay close
attention to the condition of your ship
and the morale of your crew your crew
are a pack of vicious raiders and rovers
who will mutiny against you if not kept
well fed and happy i like that that's
cool if you're survival aspects you'll
lose some progress and respawn at the
nearest discovered den or outpost
the good news is that most of your cargo
will be recovered and you'll have the
opportunity to retrieve the rest from
the wreckage but you'd better be quick
as other players can also steal it
as a pirate captain your reputation is
everything and our game tracks this
through infamy the higher your infamy
the more opportunities you'll get one of
the many ways to grow your infamy is to
take up contracts these are deals that
you can make
contracts can have great rewards if
you're successful or costs if you fail
you can also gain infamy by completing
other activities such as exploration
plundering treasure hunts investigations
dynamic events and much more you can
undertake these either solo or with
other players the world of skull and
bones is filled with riches and
resources that you'll get off the ship
and explore these islands i assume so
right lagoons and i'm surprised we
haven't seen any swimming dangerous
wildlife that you can hunt for animal
skins and meat
this is also on the bottom to harvest a
variety of raw materials such as ore and
wood that can be refined and used for
crafting i hope these pasty
[ __ ] have some scripting is an
essential activity for you to progress
as an infamous pirate
obtain blueprints and use your refined
resources to craft stronger ships
weapons and armors
in skull and bones ships serve many
different purposes
cargo ships are slower but useful if you
need to transport large volumes of loot
navigation ships sail faster but have
less cargo space and lower hull that's
interesting fire power ships have more
gun ports allowing you to deal higher
damage but are more challenging to
maneuver
similarly you can craft a wide array of
unique weapons and armor they're very
pretty that's a flamethrower
to rocket launchers oh my god
as well as different armor types which
have varying strengths and weaknesses
against incoming attacks
the envelope with your new features the
customization
arsenal create a loadout based on your
personal play style to become a force of
destruction
can you play with friends on the ship
or is it only at the hub it seems like
the ship is maybe just
you and you're out in the open
opportunities and threats are abundant
use your spy to identify lucrative trade
routes or wealthy merchant ships and
assess your prey's cargo and firepower
strategize a plan of attack based on
your opponent's defenses and take
advantage of their weak points to deal
more damage
syncing your foes from afar rewards you
with only a portion of their cargo as
some of it will be lost to the depths
getting in close to execute a boarding
maneuver will help maximize your gains
but beware you can turn from predator to
prey in a heartbeat if you attract the
unwanted attention of privateers the
merciless pirate hunters that patrol the
seas it cap if you enjoy the thrill and
get close you can also seek out other
players and reign terror on them
such pvp battles are high stakes
activities that can be rewarding if you
emerge
victorious so we'll be like sea of
thieves
in that way from your spoils of battle
personalize your individual look with
outfits that command respect
nice
you can also select from a multitude of
ship customization options to instill
fear in your enemies
yeah it does seem to me like it's one
player one ship
you could go out together in individual
ships
encounter extreme weather events like
violent storms and monstrous roadways
keep your eyes peeled for outposts which
are safe spots where you'll be able to
dock your ship for a short rest so
probably
probably only the outside trades
i guess uncover buried bounties at
outposts as you decipher treasure maps
obtained through your voyages
although all the content and skull and
bones can be done solo you might enjoy
ruling the seas with your friends while
sailing you can also easily invite other
pirates you encounter to group up
synergize your different playstyles
ships and weapons to defeat death that
confirmed one play of pup [ __ ] as you
grow stronger take on more difficult
challenges such as attacking forts and
plundering settlements and if you're
bold enough engage in dynamic events
like taking down heavily laden merchant
ships and their fleet of warship escorts
now it's up to you to write your own
story
remember there is no one path to follow
no one way to play
the world of skull and bones is yours to
discover
hey it looks very pretty i feel like um
still have questions obviously we have
one more video to go which is about ship
combat customization and progression
gameplay
i'm not that interested in this game um
definitely personal preference it's not
like i'm seeing anything about it that
makes it look like a bad game but i feel
like the idea of like solo sailing a
ship
just going to the outpost to purchase
things and then going back on the ship
just doesn't appeal to me a ton so i'm
sorry if you can hear my dog blocking i
just realized he could hear him um
yeah just uh
not not that appealing i'm sure that i
will play it like i'll try it because i
do with virtually every triple a game i
at least give it a try see
you know
what's different about it but
something about that gameplay structure
not that into it it's almost like um
like a forza horizon
but with ships a little bit um except
that you can get out of the ship
occasionally at those outposts which is
like yeah be like yeah
your destiny hubs or whatever
right like there will be there'll be
events i'll probably have a timer go to
a location participate in the group
event
um and it said you can play it solo but
it still seems to me like it's probably
online only
so yeah not that into this uh
unfortunately um it's not like it's that
different from what i expected i don't
really know what i expected
i guess i expected a narrative for
whatever reason they probably said at
some point there wasn't um
but i think i expected that so
yeah okay let's watch the last video see
if we get any more information
oh we got actual gameplay
i'll take that
interesting perspective
what what
what
skull and bones just revealed new
gameplay and is bringing you all that
good pirate action on the indian ocean
when it launches on november 8th but we
know why you're here you want to know
what was the championships and blowing
stuff up
well to learn more about your fleet and
combat so you can blow stuff up we spoke
to senior game director ryan barnard all
right let's start with chastity can you
tell me a bit about the dow the first
ship that players will captain in skull
bones
sure so as you mentioned the dow is our
smallest ship it's the it's the first
ship that you get when you start the
game as you're rescued by what will
eventually become your crew
uh it's what we call kind of the hunter
gatherer ship where you learn how you
how to gather resources and and hunt
some of the wildlife to basically
collect things that you'll need to use
to craft bigger and better ships
different weapons and different armors i
don't doubt that this like upgrade
customization system could be super
difficult the tools to start fights with
other ships or is it more of a lay low
until you can have a bigger boat
situation
if you choose to join a pvep server with
meaning pvp is enabled
you can engage
with combat with other players at any
time even though you're controlling them
as they're shooting that's what that is
spear fights is actually kind of fun
sometimes you'll be upgrading your ships
pretty quickly in the game to get
something larger where you can start
adding cannons some more firepower and
then you might want to start taking on
you know other players if you wish it's
a little bit easier to to sink them and
try to steal their loot
as players craft newer and bigger ships
what relationship will they have with
their fleet do you envision players
having one flagship that pour all of
their resources into upgrading or
maintaining an array of different ships
for different activities
at launch we will actually but you can
have multiple playable ships one player
can have multiple ships captains fleet
that we want the players to eventually
acquire
unlock and craft you could just swap
between them definitely are more in the
second camp of that question where we
want the ships to have
things that they're best at we call them
kind of tools
for the players so it's not necessarily
about upgrading to a certain ship and
then that's all you you know use for the
rest of the game you know i'm sure
players will uh get an affinity for the
certain types of play styles and ships
that they like the most interesting yeah
it's like you're swapping between which
position on this job and maybe another
ship that they want to craft and
customize out in their loadout uh for
taking on certain types of activities
okay that's cool so multiple
customizable ships if you were given a
contract or a job from another pirate to
move a large quantity of you know stolen
goods or or dangerous material from one
place to another
as one of our like quests in the game
you're definitely going to want to use a
cargo ship to be able to accomplish that
that makes so you can use anything for
most activities in the game but there
will always be the best choice for what
you're trying to accomplish
you know our pirate game our open world
pirate game with skull bones is naval
combat and we definitely wanted to be
best in class
for this type of game which which is you
know ships on the sea
so our combat is very fast you know that
you only have another ships on the sea
tech game you're really excited weapons
you choose versus your enemies will be
important uh as your income but i don't
doubt that
actually combat even based on like the
assassin's creed games other than black
flag that had ship stuff
you'll be able to do much sharper than
uh
that could turn into which is learning
and it's the only way you can actually
get all the loot and make sure that
nothing sinks to the bottom
when you're fighting what are the major
elements you need to consider for
example loadout scouting positioning
aiming etc all of our weapons and armors
are classified into an element so it's
based on you know of course we want to
be grounded in reality of this 17th
century kind of dawn of piracy so things
will be blunt or maybe they will cause
tearing of the sails or they could cause
flooding now based on the target that
you're taking on they'll have some type
of armor it could be just wood it might
be stone it might be clay which we call
terracotta and it's really pretty armor
section and based on your loadout you
will have either a good effect you know
you'll have a bonus damage to that enemy
type or you might be neutral to that
enemy type or you might actually be
doing less damage now you're never
completely inefficient you can always
take on any target with any type of
loadout but there will be better more
effective loadouts uh depending on what
you're facing also the sales are a way
that you can actually slow your enemies
in place for a a temporary period of
time where you can oh wow that's cool to
take out also all of our enemy ships
have something we call weak points so
depending on the npc enemy ships you'll
see these large
outlined red targets probably take those
out you'll do a high amount of damage
you might start the ship burning they'll
have a different effect it might change
their behavior but it'll definitely do a
lot of damage let's talk about when
combat doesn't go your way so is it
possible to flee from combat and escape
an enemy or reach a safe haven
yes so it might be more difficult to
escape a player for instance who's
chasing you but you definitely can flee
and we have safe areas around both dens
in the game which are kind of our mini
pirate villages if you will so you can
run and flee
to get back to those areas and then
you'll be safe or you can just try to
outrun or out sail
some of the enemies if they're chasing
you which also can happen and some of
our plundering activities the whole
point might be just to kind of uh uh
snatch and grab so you get what you can
while you can while you can hold off the
end of the reinforcements coming and
then you were always planning on yeah so
even that doesn't look like you actually
get off it's definitely possible
so yeah not at all like assassin's creed
that really doesn't go your way what
happens to your ship and definitely no
narrative when you're sunk what happens
to your cargo so if you do
happen to get sunk which will happen to
everyone and you lose your ship
what happens is there's a wreck created
where that happens which has a certain
amount of your materials then you'll
respawn basically either at one of the
dens or
at the nearest outpost depending on what
you choose
and most of your materials are are
mailed back to you they're insured so
you can get them in the mail uh if
you're doing that then go dolphins
no one has looted it like another player
then you'll basically get all of your
materials back and it'll just have cost
you a little bit of time and you
re-craft your ship and you keep going
nothing can catch up
skull bones is an online open world or
open c uh game
and so you definitely need to be coming
across come on players isn't that the
name of that nft platform can be uh
an option is is based on your choice so
did you are you on a pvp opt-in server
or not so if you are then you have to be
kind of wary and make sure that you're
not going to become the target of
another pirate but at any point if you
feel like you know that's not for you or
or you feel like there's maybe too many
players that are engaging in pvp on the
server on you can just opt out
immediately that's cool and go to a pbe
only server and you don't boost any
progress there's no penalty there's no
problem that's cool that you can just
swap between them yeah and then maybe
you progress a little further you get a
different ship you upgrade some of your
weapons and maybe you want to jump back
into
a pvp-enabled server because there are
benefits for playing and risking more on
the pvp-enabled servers
all right well i think i'm ready for
combat thank you all for watching check
out the skull bones worldwide gameplay
reveal on ubisoft's youtube channel take
care thanks chastity i appreciate that
um
all right well i understand what this
game is now and i feel like i'm like i
said not super interested in it
unfortunately um
i just don't really feel like it's a
thing that i'm going to enjoy i will
play it and and would be happy to be
proven wrong but the thing that gets me
about sea of thieves which like on paper
is also something i wouldn't enjoy is
that you can still hang out with your
friends and do goofy stuff and jump off
the ship and go to an island it's still
like the friend experience makes that
more fun
this not being for me doesn't mean it's
for nobody though i feel like it's
probably just going to be a little bit
more of a smaller more hardcore audience
who is very into this type of game who
really wants that pirate experience
almost like a for honor
for ubisoft i mean actually they have a
lot of games that have really smaller
very hardcore audiences like even siege
i would count uh kind of experience
where it's very um
smaller a hardcore audience at this
stage obviously that was mainstream for
a pretty long time so i do think there
will be people who will enjoy it i don't
imagine it is going to do any of the
things it's set out to do poorly like it
looks like it knows what it is and it's
probably going to nail that
i'm just not super into it which is okay
unfortunate
like i i hoped that i would be but after
this i'm like i think i'm good i'll try
it for sure when it comes out
for an hour or so but um i don't think
it's gonna be one that's like super high
on my anticipated list just down to
personal preference
it is what it is